there are reports that a gay NFL player
is going to come out sometime during the
next season and you know now players are
saying oh he shouldn't do it you know
the media and what's gonna happen blah
blah blah I personally think that the
guys in the locker room will be okay
with it most people as you're talking
about the trends and the younger people
and most of NFL players are relatively
young I think the players would all be
okay with it
or most of them at least I think that
the problem is that the media will make
such a circus no matter what that that's
actually going to be what keeps people
in the closet do you think somebody is
gonna come out this year and if so who I
don't know you know I mean I really I'm
not I have no skin in the game so to
speak I'm not I'm not a football fan I
don't see why should matter I'm not a
fan of marriage either and you know it's
just sort of weird to me like that that
that there's so much of a push for
marriage which is a defunct obsolete
institution that more often than not
ends up in complete failure I wouldn't
want to have a part of it myself
they you know there was such a push to
get in the military I wouldn't want to
have anything to do with that myself NFL
I'm not a part of it either so like if
everyone in the NFL were you know like
Iraqi vets who were married to each
other
it wouldn't I wouldn't it wouldn't
affect my day in the least
yeah so I mean that's where I yeah I
just want to sit in a cold dark I want
nothing to do with any of them and I
don't want marriage I don't want a
military Sam what do you think is it
gonna happen this year and I mean the
sports are they ready I do hope it
happens I do think within the NFL
community I think the players themselves
will be accepting of it I am worried
about people outside of the NFL
community I mean a lot of the fans you
know generally speaking are I mean we
look at football in football is
affiliated with you know red-blooded
heterosexual males rawr and I just
I do sympathize with its it is really
hard to come out all together it's hard
to come out in the entertainment
industry but without you this would
happen already I was surprised there's
been retired players in the NBA but
there is he is going to you know the if
a player comes out yes would it break
down a huge stereotype yes would it be
fantastic yes would he get a lot of
acceptance from people that support gay
rights and I do think from the NFL and
the players but I know that he would
also get a lot of discrimination too in
my opinion from some of the fans yeah
how much of this do you think is going
to depend on the players skill level
because on one hand I could see it if
you're if you're a guy that just made
the team well you don't want to wrangle
any change you know and risk getting cut
if you're a mid-level guy you it's
you're in that same thing where you just
want your job and if you're a star well
then you're risking all these
endorsements wah wah so how much of just
the actual physical athletic part of
this is going to affect who does this
well I think that you have you know that
plays into route another really
interesting point that the NFL seems
like the oddest league for this to
happen because it's the most it's the
most capricious because you don't have
guaranteed contracts so it's actually
riskier for an NFL player not just
because they for business purposes not
just the cultural ones to come out but I
mean my my prediction is that it's not
just gonna be one player why would one
of these players come out themselves
they're gonna tan them up with other you
know players that they know where
they're active and they're gonna do it
in a group why wouldn't it would make
perfect sense you kind of diffuse all
that pressure but here's the other thing
as far as acceptance in the locker room
is I think people would be beyond
shocked to know how many people within
the game know that they have gay
teammates and know who's gay and it's
completely yeah and I mean same thing a
lot of the other kind of sacred cows and
masculinity like gangster rap I mean
there's an iconic gangster rapper that
everybody in the industry knows is gay
and it just somehow doesn't so I think
that listen you're always gonna have
because there's a large NFL players come
from a large geographic expense you're
getting a lot of people who came from
parts of the country that
is still not acceptable but people the
endorsements guys that just don't want
to get you know involved in something
that it's still attached to sex
unfortunately yeah yeah I have a friend
who's a pro football player and we're
talking about something on Twitter and
he's like man I got to get off Twitter
we lost big today and one that you could
not imagine the type of what we were -
you know we had brushed up on like you
know internet commentary for political
shows Pro pro athletes on Twitter the
venom they get when they have a bad
performance or lose and someone who
actually brings they're gonna lose at
some point when they lose can they can
they take the punches yeah well that
that's a perfect segue to how I wanted
to end this which is how much of this
actually just has to do with the fact
that because of all our phones and
Twitter and Facebook and snapchat and
everything that if you were gay and on
the DL snapchat that's what the kids are
news and right I wanted to get one how
much you know like I know John amici who
was the former NBA player who came back
he said he was going to gay clubs when
they would play the Knicks in New York
but it was before everyone had a phone
so how much of this do you think is just
someone is just going to get caught
flat-out caught yeah during that we are
always on our phones wherever we go and
it's so easy to take a picture yeah but
apparently there is a gay underground
that I'm not involved in that it's
incredibly good at you know they're like
Batman and Bruce Wayne just in their
day-to-day life and they have amazing
ninja tactics and they've they've been
you know these pro players have been
able to utilize those thus far so if it
hasn't if they haven't got caught thus
far I think they're gonna be voluntarily
coming out and I think it's gonna be an
ensemble not just one guy often they're
dressed both as Batman and Bruce Wayne
Vanilla's calm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report used code TR r20 to
get this shirt and these jeans